in latin america journalism can be a
dangerous profession
and now that includes reporting the
truth about the covid19 pandemic
sonny figueroa works for guatemala's
independent investigative reporting
outlet voxpopuli
last year he and a colleague began
publishing reports about corruption
during the pandemic
that implicated close friends of the
president
that's when the president labeled us the
terrible two i was detained for 21
hours and beaten we're now getting death
threats and are being followed
constantly
a new study from reporters without
borders suggests that with the exception
of costa rica and uruguay
freedom of news media has diminished
across the board since the pandemic
began
authoritarian governments attack slander
and insult journalists in public
then it becomes an online campaign which
can quickly spiral into physical attacks
against journalists
brazilian president jayde bolsonaro is
consistently labeling the media as a
public enemy for its coverage of the
pandemic
encouraging his supporters to attack
journalists both online
and in person says colombi
a common denominator is the use of
social networks
to discredit and attack journalists who
do not paint a government's handling of
the pandemic
in a favorable light the governor of the
venezuelan state of arawa
accused journalist gregoria diaz of
being paid
to lie in a report about the acute
shortage of hospital beds and medicine
she tells me she's being investigated
under an anti-terrorism financing law
i won't deny that i'm frightened that
i'm always looking over my shoulder
that i don't know when this so-called
charge against me will result in my
arrest
and in chile a prominent independent
journalist who suggested that the health
ministry was under reporting the number
of covid19
infections and deaths was accused of
spreading fake news
of trying to destroy the government and
of being anti-patriotic
it was a message to the rest of the
media to behave
if you wanna be chilean if you wanna be
you wanna show patriotism you wouldn't
contest the official
data that was the message the reporters
without borders report
makes the point that in the context of a
global sanitary emergency
journalism is the primary vaccine
against a virus called
disinformation yet theirs and our own
investigation
suggests that the pandemic is actually
being used to justify
in many cases limiting transparency
and freedom of expression see uc newman
al jazeera
santiago okay that's the picture
in south america let's look more broadly
now at the world press freedom index
which looks at 180 countries in all
it shows journalists are partially or
completely blocked from doing their jobs
in more than 130 nations
the worst offenders north korea china
vietnam iran and syria
several governments have been accused of
using the pandemic to silence critics
with laws against what they see
as fake news christopher sabatini is a
senior researcher fellow for latin
america at chatham house in london he
joins us on skype
christopher sabatini welcome to the
newshour which countries are the worst
outstripping other nations around the
globe
latin america has always had a difficult
relationship between especially during
rising uh polarization uh the rise of
populist governments
um but and so consequently as a result
the reporters without borders has listed
latin america is one of the most
dangerous regions in the world
to conduct journalism what makes it
particularly striking is that these
in many cases these are under
governments that are nominally elected
nominally democratic and so what we've
seen
is already this these attacks against
journalists this polarization
in which freedom of expression is caught
in the middle between
oftentimes uh legitimate concerns about
uh information and and the need for data
as well as the autocratic ambitions of
elected leaders
and now we have the justification of
covid uh into that and so we're seeing
places this year
previous report mentioned in chile in
guatemala
in which journalists are particularly
being targeted um and
reasons that sort of uh deny the very
threat of covet
and undermine the ability to address it
do presidents prime ministers
health ministers around the world in in
the prism of covet and coronavirus maybe
only have themselves to blame here
because
you know the first three six months of
this
15 18 months of coronavirus was kind of
defined in a sense
at those presidential and prime
ministerial meetings where ministers and
presidents would stand up and say
we're gonna win we're gonna beat it it's
to be okay in three months it's going to
be okay in 20
in in 2021 and it clearly was never
going to be okay and the ecosystem of
reporting now is
live coverage on international
television news channels that's recorded
it's dead easy to spool back
six months nine months and say but sir
you said such and such a thing
in january 2020 and here we are one year
later and nothing's improved
this is precisely it peter the classic
case right now is india
where modi and india many people thought
they had dodged a bullet in being able
to
avoid a massive infection rate and now
we see of course the terrible news
coming out of india of death rates
shortages
and modi has actually asked that the
modi government has asked that twitter
uh prohibit any sort of information that
contradicts the government and so
in many of these cases what were once
considered success stories
and uh presidents such as of course the
former president trump in the united
states being somewhat cavalier about
their ability to address this
are now finding it's much more
complicated as a policy issue
at the same time as they're sort of
getting embarrassed by a media that is
confronting them directly
and demonstrating and revealing data
that embarrasses them
and puts them in doubt in terms of their
own sort of in the case of modi or trump
or bolsonaro or amlo in
mexico the mexican president sort of
challenging their own sort of
uh macho attitudes towards containing
the virus
i guess it's a tough call for
journalists because
part of the ecosystem of journalism has
changed it's people doing their own
thing it's people doing
investigative journalism with no backup
no support per se
from the editor in the newsroom those
days
have either died or they are dying it's
people posting stuff on facebook it's
citizen journalism
but it's perfectly good journalism and i
guess for those individuals they've got
to take a tough call here either
they go back to basics and carry on
doing and asking the tough questions
or they have to leave the country they
have to leave their own country because
the potential tariff might be
a jail term on trumped-up charges
yeah that's exactly right first of all
if you notice a number of these
journalists that are being attacked or
media sources or independent media we're
not talking
often times traditional media it's not
the al jazeera's the cnns or
or the new york times in many cases and
in these countries it's more independent
media that is sprung up oftentimes
internet based
uh the second is of course as you say
sort of independent journalists or even
citizens posting information
um but what makes this particularly
toxic or threatening to the government
is it occurs in a moment when there is
the government is prohibiting uh
clear access to data reliable data on
infection rates so
they're particularly threatened because
they are limiting the media's uh
access to information and so they're
being caught within
a toxic environment for them uh that
then threatens journalists and so we've
seen for example in the case of
guatemala the guatemalan president has
said it needs to put
he needs to put the media on quarantine
in other words he wants to basically
shut it down
and limit its access to information and
his ability to report and that is a very
troubling sign
christopher this is an important story
that does need to be told perhaps again
and again good to talk to you a really
really compelling conversation
christopher
sabatini there from chatham house in
london